we heard you speak earlier in the week
at the summit in glasgow addressing
those world leaders they were all
setting sitting in front of you what is
it you wanted to say what was your
message from the pacific islands to the
rest of the world
you know i had a very limited time i
only had two minutes and the the main
message i wanted to send was for them to
watch their words and cop and to also
know that we're not drowning in the
pacific that we're fighting and we're
also resilient we're not we're resilient
and not just victims
how are you feeling the effects of
climate change in samoa in the pacific
islands because world leaders talk about
climate change happening right now and
in your case it's on your shoreline it's
on your doorstep
yes we live with the consequences of
inaction and so
we see the the change in the weather the
coral bleaching the fish stock declining
the increase in cyclones the the heavy
flooding the long drought everything
that you would imagine the climate
crisis looking like for you
or in in bigger countries for the future
is what we're experiencing in the
present
brianna do you felt heard because there
were so many young speakers at the
summit in glasgow and it really does
seem to be young people that are
pressing the sense of urgency because we
say you know it is our young people that
are going to inherit the earth and end
up dealing with this mess
are you feeling heard
i feel seen which is different from
being heard i think we will only truly
know if we've been heard once the
actions start following the words of
call and that will only come after cop
when the real work begins
it's so hard isn't it brianna because
you feel what more can you do you are
telling them firsthand how climate
change is affecting your islands
if it continues as it is it will
devastate your island so you are giving
them first-hand account of climate
change happening
right now you do wonder what more you
could do
yes and and that's
that's why we keep showing up to these
these cops why we keep on showing up in
this space is because
even though we might not know the the
thing that will finally make change
happen we keep doing everything that we
can and we keep showing up because um
the cost of silence is too big of a
price to pay for us
and
it's entering the final days the summit
in glasgow and this is when the
decisions start to be made i think
there's um
197 involved parties in these
negotiations in the final days to get
some concrete commitments to get a time
frame to get a timetable to get a method
of reporting back so we can see how
countries make progress
what is your call to action to those
negotiators as they head into these
final days
the call to action has always been as
simple as ambitious mitigation that we
know
it is keeping fossil fuels in the ground
and and ending all exploration of these
industries that feed the climate crisis
and and moving towards a more
sustainable and renewable energy source
for our planet we know what's destroying
us we know it has to end and it really
will just take that political will to
finally get us over those those goals
that we've made for so long
and and the second ask for pacific
island in particular is around climate
financing is how do we make sure that
justice is found by the nations who are
living with the consequences of climate
change but have done so little or have
not even made like a little speck in the
the global emissions and so it is
adaptation and its mitigation and and
making sure that those goals and those
targets are ambitious are as ambitious
as we need to be
yeah that is one of the big decisions
that's being made at the end of this
summit how they control the flow of
money across borders to make sure that
developing countries and and smaller uh
islands um like yours are helped and
you started your journey as a climate
activist at the young age of 11.
and i just wonder what your hopes for
the future are now how do you keep being
seen as you are now and how eventually
do you think you'll be heard because
after everybody leaves glasgow
you need to keep this up this momentum
needs to keep going if we're to get
anywhere
my ultimate hope for the future and what
i hope can come out of cop is that young
people no longer have to come to these
summits is that i've talked to so many
young youth activists who because of the
time of year they've missed their prom
they've missed their graduation
i missed my prom and my graduation
because i was at cop
as a teenager i was like cop 21
and it's like this cycle is continuously
happening happening and these activists
are getting younger and there's becoming
more of them because we know this crisis
and and we know that climate leadership
can be led by us and so my hope is that
the adults at the table can finally
have that political will like i said in
the beginning of this interview to do
the right thing so that our young ones
can be kids and not have to show up to
conferences on the other side of the
world
well brianna thank you so much for
talking to us as you said you only have
two minutes to speak at cop but it
definitely made an impact and you've
made an impact with us here uh this
evening um brianna ferran um from samoa
from the pacific islands speaking up for
her islands and the effect of climate
change and talking about what needs to
be done to save not just the pacific
islands but as you said it uh in your
speech save the pacific islands save the
world brianna thank you thank you for
having me